The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
REBECCA SAXE: I was
supposed to go before Ken,
and thank goodness Ken insisted
he went before me, because
in some ways that was the
most amazing introduction
to my research program that you
could possibly have ever had.
And it articulated deeply
why social intelligence
should pervade our
thinking about the mind
and brain and the
range of phenomena
that people mean in
social intelligence--
from extremely complex phenomena
that govern the interactions
of large groups of
people, like war,
to incredibly minute
phenomena, like
whether you can get your
hand to a target in 100
milliseconds or less.
I think that when people
talk about social cognition
they do actually mean
all of those things.
And that is both
thrilling-- when
you work in social cognition--
and also terrifying,
especially when people are
hoping for a coherent theory
of all of that.
I think that trying to get a
coherent account of everything
from your hand motions and your
perception of other people's
hand motions all the way
to politics and sociology
is daunting and,
frankly, deeply unlikely.
And so, by contrast to Ken--
who starts with, let's
look at social interactions
and see what's
there, which I think
is a very awesome approach--
I'm going to take almost
the opposite approach, which
is say, there's one thing
that's probably there a lot.
Let's try to study that one
thing in many different ways
and contexts.
And the one thing, as Lou said
that I'm going to talk about--
although, contrary to
many people's impressions,
is not the only
thing I work on--
is this ability that we have.
OK, so a little demo of the
problem that I work on--
and because it's early in the
morning and everybody needs
to wake up, I'm going to get
you guys to do this as a task,
so as an experiment.
So in this experiment,
I'm going to ask
you guys to make a moral
judgment of a character.
Her name is Grace.
And the way you're going
to make a moral judgment
is, I'm going to tell
you something she did,
and you're going to
say how much blame
she deserves-- moral
blame, how wrong that was.
You're going to do so
by raising your hand.
The more wrong it was,
the higher your hand goes.
And everybody has to vote.
OK?
Yes?
OK, so this is a
story about Grace.
She's on a tour of
a chemical factory.
So they're walking around
being given a tour.
There's a break in the tour.
And she goes to make coffee.
Another girl on the tour
asks for a cup of coffee
with sugar in it.
So Grace goes to the coffee
machine to make a cup of coffee
for herself and for
this other girl.
Next to the coffee
machine is a jar
of white powder
labeled sugar, so Grace
thinks the powder is sugar.
She puts some of that powder
in the other girl's coffee.
But it turns out that
powder is contaminated
by a dangerous toxic
poison, and when the girl
drinks the coffee, she dies.
How much blame
does Grace deserve
for putting the
powder in the coffee?
OK, now what if I slightly
changed that story?
So next to the coffee machine
there's a jar of white powder
and it's labeled
dangerous toxic poison.
So grace thinks that the
powder is toxic poison.
And she puts some of the
poison in the coffee,
and when the girl
drinks it, she dies.
Now how much blame
does Grace deserve
for putting the
powder in the coffee?
So what's characteristic
about these stories is
that, in the story I
told you, everything
was the same from the beginning,
the scenario where Grace was,
to the action and the outcome--
that the girl died.
But your moral
judgments differed
by about the entire
scale that I gave you,
from saying that she deserved
almost no blame to saying
that she deserved pretty much as
much blame as you could reach.
And that's the same
kind of moral judgment
we get from typical
human subjects
and also from MIT
undergraduates, which
say that in scenarios
like the one I gave you,
what matters most for the moral
blame that we assign is not
what happened-- did
somebody die or not-- or how
bad that outcome was.
But it's what Grace thought
she was doing, whether she
thought the powder was sugar or
she thought that it was poison.
I should just say right away
that I set up that scenario.
I gave you the
best case scenario
for the role of beliefs.
It's easy to make these
things way more complicated.
But that scenario isolates
one important feature
of our moral judgment and
also an important feature
of a lot of the rest of
our social cognition.
It's not how we avoid bumping
into people in subways,
but a lot of the other
kind of social cognition
we do about the people that are
around us, which is our ability
to assign thoughts or internal
mental states to other people.
So in psychology,
this ability has
been studied from kind of
relatively simple perceptual
phenomena like assigning
intentions and goals
to simple moving
characters in an animation.
This is the very famous
Heider and Simmel example
from the '40s.
This ability has been studied
all the way to understanding
some of the most complex,
abstract ideas that we ever
encounter, like the famous
apocryphal statement attributed
to Alan Greenspan, which is, "I
know you think you understand
what you thought I said, but
I don't think you realize that
what you heard was
not what I meant. "
So to the degree that our minds
let us make any sense of that
at all, we're using our
ability to make sense of other
people's minds.
How many people here have
seen the standard test
of this ability of thinking
about other people's thoughts,
which the false belief task?
How many people have seen
somebody do a false belief task
or give a false belief task?
How many people would like
to see a false belief task?
OK, so then I'm just
going to show you one.
So as I said, the scope
of tests of our ability
to think about other people's
thoughts or internal states
is very large.
I'm saying that two ways on
purpose because actually,
although these are
often conflated,
I think there's a really
important difference between
thinking about
epistemic states--
so things like what
you know, what you see,
and what you think--
versus states like what
you want and how you feel.
I think it turns out empirically
that those are really
different problems.
And I'm almost exclusively going
to talk about the first one,
so how we think about what other
people see, think, and know--
but not want or feel.
At the end I'll come back
to wanting and feeling.
OK, so how do we know what
other people have seen
and what they think
and what they know?
This problem was set up
as kind of a litmus test
for our ability to think
about other people's minds,
starting in the late
'70s and coming out
of comparative psychology.
So the origin of this
problem for psychology
is, everybody knows
humans could do this.
What about animals?
And actually, the debate
about whether this capacity
for thinking about
other people's thoughts
is or is not shared with
which other animals has
gone on continuously
since the late '70s
and has not been resolved.
That's the origin
of this debate,
and it's not resolved yet.
But it led to the construction
of this particular task
as a litmus test for
what one person knows
about somebody else's thoughts,
called the false belief task.
And so here's what a false
belief task looks like.
This is being given to a
five-year-old human child.
This is the first pirate.
His name is Ivan.
Do you know what
pirates really like?
CHILD: What?
REBECCA SAXE: Pirates really
like cheese sandwiches.
CHILD: Cheese?
I love cheese!
REBECCA SAXE: So Ivan has his
cheese sandwich, and he says,
yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I really love cheese sandwiches.
And Ivan puts his
sandwich over here
on top of the pirate chest.
And Ivan says, you know what,
I need a drink with my lunch.
So Ivan goes to get a drink.
And while Ivan is
away, the wind comes,
and it blows the sandwich
down onto the grass.
And now, here comes
the other pirate.
This pirate is called Joshua.
And Joshua also really
loves cheese sandwiches.
So Joshua has a cheese
sandwich, and he says,
yum, yum, yum, yum, yum--
I love cheese sandwiches.
And he puts his cheese
sandwich over here
on top of the pirate chest.
CHILD: So that one is his.
REBECCA SAXE: That
one's Joshua's.
CHILD: And then his
is on the ground.
REBECCA SAXE: Yeah.
That's exactly right.
CHILD: So he won't
know which one is his.
REBECCA SAXE: Oh-- so now
Joshua goes off to get a drink.
Ivan comes back.
And he says, I want
my cheese sandwich.
So which one do you think
Ivan's going to take?
CHILD: I think he's
gonna take that one.
REBECCA SAXE: Yeah, you think
he's gonna take that one.
All right, let's see.
CHILD: I told you.
REBECCA SAXE: Oh
yeah, you were right.
He took that one.
OK, so that's called passing
the false belief task.
And the thing that's
reported in scientific papers
is that he correctly
predicted that Ivan
would take Joshua's sandwich.
Although if you
watch the video, you
see that the knowledge the
kid is bringing to bear
is a way richer than just
his correct prediction
and includes him, in fact,
trying to stop me in the story
to warn me of what's coming.
So it's a rich interpretation
of what other people know
and don't know and will know
and haven't seen and so forth.
The reason why this
task became so famous
is that not all participants
perform the same way.
And so one class of
participants who've
become the focus
of intense scrutiny
is slightly younger kids,
namely three-year-olds.
So I'll give you a sense
of what that looks like.
This is a three-year-old.
He's paid equally rapt attention
throughout the entire story.
And we come to the
crucial moment,
and he's asked again
the same question.
And Ivan says, I want
my cheese sandwich.
Which sandwich is
he going to take?
Do you think he's
going to take that one?
Let's see what happens.
Let's see what he does.
Here comes Ivan.
He says, I want my
cheese sandwich.
And he takes this one.
Uh oh-- why did
he take that one?
OK, and so the
traditional read of what
just happened there is that's
a kid who gets wanting, right.
Ivan wants his cheese sandwich.
But he doesn't get believing.
He doesn't understand that
because Ivan left his cheese
sandwich on top of
the pirate chest
and he doesn't
know that it's been
moved that he'll believe
that that sandwich is his,
and that his actions
depend on his own beliefs--
his internal representation
of the world,
rather than the true
state of the world,
namely which one is
his cheese sandwich.
And that's the source of
both this wrong prediction--
why does he say that he'll
take his cheese sandwich--
and the wrong explanation.
So when he goes to take
the other cheese sandwich,
the one that's
actually Joshua's,
then we say, why did he do that.
And again, this is
typical performance
that the little
kids confabulate.
They come up with
a reason why he
might have taken
that other cheese
sandwich which is
consistent with him
not wanting his own anymore.
So in this case, it's that
his fell on the ground.
He doesn't want his anymore.
That's why he's taking
Joshua's sandwich.
And that pattern of
performance was interpreted
as evidence of conceptual change
and development-- kids going
from having a partial
understanding of other people's
minds that included
wanting to a richer
interpretation of
other people's minds
that also included believing.
So what I want to get from this
actually is not whether or not
it's true that there's
conceptual change between three
and five, although I
do think it is true,
but just an idea of what
capacity are we talking about.
We're talking about
the capacity actually
that the five-year-old
showed, however they got it
and whenever they got it.
It's this capacity to, when
watching other people act
in the world, bring to bear--
both spontaneously and when
asked--
a conception of the
other person having
beliefs, perceptual
history, knowledge,
an internal representation of
the world that guides actions.
And so that is what I'm going
to call thinking about thought.
And the idea that
this is a domain
that you could
study on its own--
well, there's two
questions here.
One is can you
study this at all.
And the second one
is can you study
it separate from the
whole rest of cognition.
Both of those are related
to Liz, and indeed Nancy,
and many people's worries that
you could never make progress
on a problem like
this, which I share.
I share the worry that you could
never make progress on this.
And so what I want
to tell you guys
is two phases of my attempt to
make progress on understanding
how we do that.
How do we think
about other people
as containing internal mental
lives, mental representations.
I'm going to talk
about just fMRI,
although I do use other
methods to study this problem.
But I think fMRI has been
both an incredible gift
to our ability to
understand the human mind
and also imposes a huge
number of limitations
on what we can discover.
And so what I'm going to
tell you about is just
a tiny bit of my phase
one investigations using
the early strategies
that fMRI allowed us
and then a more
in-depth look at how
I'm using more modern techniques
in fMRI to try to get further.
This is partly because
I think it's interesting
what we've learned.
But it's mainly because I
think that you guys might not
actually want to know
about theory of mind,
but you might want
to know if you
can fMRI to study interesting
questions about the human mind
and how.
And so I'm going to
focus on three ways
to use modern techniques
in fMRI to study
interesting representations
in the human mind,
hoping that either you'll learn
something about theory of mind
or something about
how you could use fMRI
to pursue your own interests.
So phase one in fMRI, which as
Liz said started 15 years ago,
is--
OK, thinking about
other people's thoughts,
is that a thing in the
mind and brain at all?
So when you go to start studying
something, you want to know,
am I studying a
part of a problem,
or am I just studying the
whole mind, our entire capacity
to think any interesting,
complicated thought.
And fMRI turns out to
be more useful, mostly,
when you're studying
something that
is in some way compartmentalized
from the rest of the mind.
And so one question is-- is
theory of mind, the ability
to think about other people's
thoughts, in any sense
its own problem?
Or are we just studying
the whole problem
of human intelligence
and capacity?
So that was sort of
the first question
that we set out to answer.
We and a number of
people did this.
And the way we did it
is that we had people
in an fMRI machine
doing basically
an adult version of the pirates
task that I just showed you.
So they read short
verbal stories
that describe somebody who
comes to have a false belief.
This is an example.
So Ann puts lasagna
in the blue dish.
Ian takes the lasagna
out and puts spaghetti
in the blue dish.
And then we ask, what does
Ann think is in the blue dish.
OK, so this is a very simple
encapsulation of our ability
to represent what
somebody else thinks
and separate it from
the state of the world.
So while you were
doing that, you
were clearly using
your theory of mind.
But you were clearly
also using many,
many, many other capacities
of your mind and brain,
like the capacity
to see those words,
to know they are
words in English,
to put them together
in sentences,
and then to make a response
by pushing a button.
So we're using everything
from your eyes to your fingers
and most of the
brain in between.
And then the
question is, the part
that required you
thinking about thoughts--
is there any sense in which
that's special or different
from the whole rest of the
logical and cognitive capacity
of your brain?
So to ask that question
we designed a control
condition in which
you similarly read
stories that involve
something that was true
and becomes false.
You need to think
about those two
and respond using
a button press.
But in this case, what it
is is a state of the world.
So this is an island and
a photograph taken of it.
Then the photograph, of
course, stays the same.
But the world changes.
So there's a
volcano that erupts.
And now we can ask you
either about the photograph,
what's in the
photograph, or what's
the world actually like now.
And the idea is that
in this comparison
you need the ability
to see the stimuli,
read English, put together
your logical thoughts,
and choose a button
press in both cases.
But only in the first
case do you also
need to think about
other people's thoughts.
And so that comparison would
let us look for brain regions
where blood oxygenation
or metabolism is higher
if you're thinking about
other people's thoughts.
So that is old news now.
The simple answer is that we
and many, many other groups that
tried this in many
different ways
found a whole group
of brain regions
where metabolism or blood
oxygenation is higher
if you need to think about
other people's thoughts
in the stories.
Part of what's interesting
though about this brain region
is not just the claims
about selectivity.
The other thing that's
interesting-- and extremely
fortunate for
research purposes--
is that the signal
is ridiculously
strong and reliable.
The difference between thinking
about somebody else's thoughts
and other logical problems--
in terms of how
significant, how reliable,
how similar across
individual subjects--
is comparable to the difference
between looking at gradings
and not looking at gratings
in V1, which is nuts.
That's crazy that something
this complicated and abstract
would have an unbelievably
large, robust, reliable signal
in individual subjects.
I'll give you a
little hint of it.
But everyone who has
ever come through my lab
says that they never
believe me until they see it
in their own data.
And you can do this in
any individual subject.
So here's just three
individual participants
after five minutes to
10 minutes of scanning.
You need to read only between
10 and 20 total stories
in literally five to 10 minutes.
And every individual
subject basically
shows the same pattern
of brain activation
for thinking about thoughts
compared to the other stories.
It's just this unbelievably
strong signal, literally
unbelievable.
It should not possibly be
true on any a priori story,
except for maybe the
story Ken just told you
about how social cognition
is the fundamental basis
of everything.
When you look inside this brain
region, this is in one of them.
I'm showing you pictures
of the right TPJ.
It's one of five
cortical regions.
I'm going to talk
a lot about it,
because the data from the right
TPJ are particularly clean.
So in the right TPJ, that's
average percent singal change
in some of our early
experiments to stories
about beliefs
compared to control
stories about photographs.
Two things are striking.
One is that it's a
really big difference--
a big positive signal when
you're reading stories
about beliefs, and not
much when you're reading
stories about photographs.
The other thing
is that it starts
at the time you start
reading the story.
So you start reading a story,
and the signal starts to go up.
This is just showing that
difference in how much
you think about thoughts
contributes a lot of variance
across many different
individual stories.
And if you look
within the story,
it's the time when you're
thinking about a thought
that you get activity
in this brain region.
We also spend a
bunch of time saying
fMRI, as everybody knows,
is a correlational signal.
Does this brain region
actually play a causal role
in letting you think
about thoughts?
And so we did a version
of the same experiment
that I gave you guys on
moral reasoning with TMS
and asked whether using
TMS on the right TPJ
compared to a
control brain region
would disproportionately
affect how
you use people's mental states
in making moral judgments.
We showed that after TMS to the
right TPJ compared to a control
brain region, people use
the beliefs of the character
less in making their
moral judgments.
And so where we get to after
all of this is a hypothesis.
This was after about eight
years that I was saying here's
what we've learned.
We've learned that the
right TPJ is selectively
involved in theory
of mind, and so
selectively depends on all the
experiments I didn't show you.
That's a claim
about specificity.
But "involved in"--
that's a euphemism.
And it's a euphemism
that I think
a lot of cognitive
neuroscientists
use and are satisfied with.
But after a while, I found
it deeply embarrassing,
like-- what on earth
is "involved in"?
And so what I want
to talk to you about
is how to get beyond the
euphemism of "involved in"
in using fMRI to
understand the mind.
This is what fMRI in my
hands typically looks like.
You read a bunch of
stories in the scanner,
and we record activity in
the brain region-- here,
for example, the right TPJ--
while you're reading
those stories.
And so our traditional
measures are the measures that
let us estimate
specificity and selectivity
and answer all the
questions you guys asked me.
Is it more for
this, less for that?
What makes it go up?
What makes it go down?
Those measures, called
univariate measures,
measure the amount of
activity in that region,
on average, as you
read a different story.
So you get something
that looks like this.
And what you show is
that this brain region
responds a certain amount.
Or there's a certain amount
of activity metabolism
in this brain region while
you're reading that story.
And so what we do
with that is we
make arguments about selectivity
and these kinds of things
that we've been talking
about this entire time.
And if you did that in
the reverse direction,
you'd say, OK, what can we
learn about these stimuli
or the representation
of these stimlui--
these two stimuli--
from activity like this?
Well OK, both of them
are within the set
that this brain
region cares about.
They both elicit high activity.
So both stories involve
thinking about thoughts.
And one of the things
we showed early on
is that activity
generalizes in the sense
that many different stories
about many different kinds
of thoughts all illicit
activity in this brain region.
And so from the amount of
activity in this brain region,
you know something like that
story is about thoughts.
And I told you that I
think that that is related
to this idea of involvement.
This brain region
is involved when
a story describes thoughts.
OK, what's wrong with that for
making theoretical progress
on theory of mind is
that, with respect
to the representation of
other people's thoughts,
that doesn't tell us anything
about how our brain does it.
So for example, what
it doesn't tell us--
it doesn't tell us how
we know who thinks what.
It doesn't tell us
why they think that.
what the consequences
were of them thinking that.
It doesn't tell us
how our brains track
or represent any of
these properties.
So the things that would make
something a theory of mind--
a representation of who thinks
what, why, and with what
consequences--
we can't see in the
univariate signal.
So what I would like
to make progress on,
what I think we're starting to
make progress on using MVPA,
is getting beyond that this
brain region is involved
in theory of mind and
trying to ask something
about what is represented
in this brain region.
And we're doing this using
a key assumption which
comes from systems
neuroscience, which
is that we can think
of representations
in terms of population codes
of features or dimensions.
And I want to say that
right now because that
is an old, discredited
theory of concepts,
but nevertheless a powerful
strategy in neuroscience,
including in this context.
It's another thing I could
talk at greater length about.
So the idea that
we're going to look at
is that populations of neurons
will respond differentially
to features or dimensions
of our stimuli.
And by figuring out what the
main features or dimensions are
of our stimuli, we
can infer something
about the representation
underlying--
the representation that this
brain region participates in--
and that is the representation
of theory of mind.
OK, So what is MVPA?
I'll briefly say my idea
of how to think about MVPA.
So a traditional analysis--
the things that we were doing
mostly for the first
15 years of fMRI--
are called now
univariate analyses.
You would take a
patch of cortex,
as represented by a bunch of
pixels in the brain-- they're
called voxels, a bunch of
volume elements in the brain
you're studying-- and look at
the average amount of response.
The unit of analysis was
the amount of response.
These experiments
typically proceed
in what's called now the
forward or encoding direction.
So that is, you
have some hypothesis
of what might be represented.
You vary it in your stimuli.
And you look at how varying
that dimension in your stimuli
causes differences in the
magnitude of the thing
that you're measuring.
What was most effectively
revealed by these analyzes
are differences in the cortex
at the scale of regions, what
one region as opposed
to another region does,
so what the kind of large-scale
structure of the cortex
is on the scale maybe
of a centimeter.
And that turns out
in many contexts--
especially in the back
half of the brain,
the representation regions--
to correspond in some
sense to the stimulus type.
What kind of thing
were you dealing with?
What is it that you're
looking at or processing?
And then this is, I
think, in some ways
the shortest possible
version of Nancy's
amazing 30-year research
program of figuring out
how to parcellate
cortex into chunks
of about a centimeter that
correspond to something
about the type of stimulus
that we're presenting to you.
And divide up in this
forward direction.
Think of a type of stimulus.
Find the brain region where
the magnitude of response
is selective to
that stimulus type.
MVPA analyses-- so
multivoxel pattern analysis--
are contrasted to
this in the sense
that they tend to
be multivariant.
So that is, you're looking
at not how much on average
a group of voxels respond,
but the relative response
between one voxel and
another from trial to trial.
So you're looking
at which of two
voxels is higher or
lower than the other,
rather than what their
overall amount of activity is.
It has mostly,
though not always,
been used in the reverse
or decoding direction.
So the answer at the end is--
given that I got this
pattern, what can I
figure out about the stimulus?
So that's the way many of
these analyzes proceed.
You ask, having
done all of this,
now I get a new
pattern of activity.
What can I decode
about the stimulus
from the new pattern
of neural activity?
To me, these analyzes
are most interesting
when they're looking for
things smaller than a region.
This is again another
interesting long conversation
that I would have
got to at the end.
All the mathematical
techniques of MVPA
could be used to rediscover
all of the things Nancy already
discovered using the
traditional analyses.
And in fact, if you
use them uncarefully
that's what you're
most likely to do,
because those are huge
signals in the brain.
And so if you're not
careful, what you will do
is just re-go over old
territory with new math.
I am more interested
in these techniques
when they let us see things
we could never see before.
So when, instead of telling us
about region level differences
or centimeter scale
differences, they're
telling us about much
smaller and more interleaved
populations on the spatial
and representational skills
and when what they're
revealing are not the type
classifications of stimuli--
so the things that decide
whether this region
or that region will
be more activated--
but for a given type
of stimuli, what
are the key dimensions
of representation.
So the reason why I think MVPA
is giving a new life to fMRI
is because many of the
most interesting questions
about cognition and
cognitive science
that we wanted to answer and
that fMRI never let us answer
were about within-stimulus
type features or dimensions.
What makes this face look
like person A versus person B?
What makes this thought predict
moral blame versus not blame?
So within-type dimensions of
importance-- and MVP I think
is letting us do that in its
most interesting applications.
The intuition here is that--
think about a region, like the
right TPJ, or the face area
if you think about faces.
Or V1 is often where I start,
because we know enough about V1
that I can use it to imagine
what we're talking about.
So you can think
about that whole area.
And you think, what can we
learn about what it does.
So let's talk about V1.
Does everybody here
have some sense of V1?
Everyone's had kind of a first
introductory neuroscience
class, OK.
So V1 is called V1 because
information goes from your eyes
to the LGN of your
thalamus to V1.
It's the first cortical
stop of visual information.
And one way that we know that
it's very involved in vision
is that if you
were doing visions,
if you're seeing visual stimuli,
you get a big response in V1.
If you're not seeing
visual stimuli,
like you're hearing
auditory stimuli
or feeling tactile stimuli, you
don't get a big response in V1.
So that's a selectivity
type measure.
It's a univariate measure for
the amount of activity in VI
that tells you V1 is
in some way involved
in vision, relative to
audition or somatic sensation.
But that misses pretty much all
the interesting contributions
that visual cortex
makes to vision.
What we want to
know about V1 is not
that it is involved when
you are doing vision
and not involved when
you are not doing vision.
We want to know
what transformations
over the information
coming from LGN
is V1 implementing-- what
computational transformations,
what representations.
And that's why theories
like Marr's theory-- which
say that it's edge detection,
or that there are receptive
fields, that it depends on
the contrast, the position,
and the orientation
of the information
in the field that counts as an
account of the representation
that V1 forms of the image
in the first bottom-up sweep.
In a way, that's saying
"it's involved in vision"
doesn't even begin to count.
OK, so the question is, if
we were going to look at V1,
could we discover from
fMRI that V1, for example,
has an orientation
map, that neurons in V1
have an orientation preference?
That's a key feature
of neurons in V1.
It's a key feature of
the computation V1 does.
Different from the
LGN and the retina
is the orientation map, a
preference for the orientation
of a contrast and edge.
And the answer in
standard analyses
is-- no, you can't,
because V1 as a whole
will activate to big images
regardless of the orientation
of the content of the image.
So you need to be able to get
to something more fine-grained
than V1.
You need to be able to say there
are different subpopulations
of neurons inside
V1, some of which
will be responding when a line
is like this, and some of which
will be responding when
a line is like that.
And that's the
decoding perspective
that says, if we
wanted to look at V1
and know is the line
like this or like that,
the way we would tell is not how
much activity there is in V1.
But is there relatively
more activity
in the population
of neurons that
responds like this, or in
the subpopulation of neurons
that responds like that?
And it's the relative activity
in those two populations
that would let you say,
is the line like this,
or is it like that.
That's population coding
or population decoding.
And then you take that
to the fMRI level.
So now you want to
say, can we tell
which of those
two subpopulations
is more active in fMRI?
Now, if you could measure
the individual neurons--
so if you know these neurons
prefer this and these neurons
prefer that, and then I measure
your firing patterns-- then
decoding from the
population is simple.
What makes it
really hard in fMRI
is that the unit of measurement
is the blood oxygenation
in 100,000 neurons, 200,000
neurons, maybe 500,000 neurons.
And so it seems
potentially really unlikely
that you would be able to
tell from the fMRI signal
whether the neurons that
prefer bars like this or bars
like this are more active,
because they're all
intermixed inside a single
measurement in fMRI.
And so it's not stupid that
we used to focus on things
like how much activity.
The reason we used to focus
on how much activity with fMRI
is that it was quite
plausible that that's all fMRI
could tell us.
The neural populations, like
orientation preferring neurons
in V1, were too spatially
mixed to tell the difference
between them in fMRI.
And so what we were going to
get was just how much activity
in the population as a whole.
So the traditional way of
thinking about what you got out
of fMRI is, yes, you would see
differences across voxels, so
these fine spatial patterns.
But there's so many
things that could
cause fine spatial patterns
that we don't care about--
noise, for a start.
Where the blood vessels
happen to be is another thing.
And so people assumed,
I think very reasonably,
that because fMRI is such
a core spatial measure,
that the only thing
it could tell you
was the average over
the millions of neurons
that make up a region.
And there's a key
intuition underlying MVPA.
So there's the big signal
which is the regional signal--
V1 and vision-- and
there's lots of noise.
But there might
also be inside there
a tiny bit of spatial pattern
that says something like--
well, this voxel happens
to have more neurons that
prefer one orientation.
And this voxel happens
to have more neurons that
prefer a different orientation.
And so from the relative
activity in those two voxels,
we could still tell
you the orientation--
even though that would be a
tiny, subtle little signal
superimposed on top of
this massive signal, which
is the average of V1.
That was the intuition behind
multivoxel pattern analysis
when it was first proposed.
And it's now sweeping the fMRI
world, many different versions
of these analyses.
And so actually what
I'm going to do again--
to give you a more concrete
sense of what this is
and how it works--
is I'm just going
to show you two different
ways MVPA is done concretely
in my lab to try to get you more
of a sense of what's going on.
And we can come back to
these more general issues
of what it's measuring
and what that means.
OK, so here's what it
looks like when we do MVPA.
Again, if it helps, think
about the analogy from vision.
We've gone from saying, is
this vision or audition,
to trying to say which
orientation is it.
So we're moving from saying,
is this theory of mind or not,
to trying to say anything
interesting about the space
within theory of mind--
some dimension that might
matter within theory of mind.
And the first
dimension or potential
feature that we wanted to look
for we chose because it really
matters to human judgments.
And it's the one
that you guys did
in the very beginning
of my talk--
telling the difference
between somebody who knowingly
or unknowingly commits murder.
That, as you saw, makes a huge,
huge difference in behavior.
And also, we know it's
represented in the right TPJ
because of the TMS experiment.
If we mess up the
signaling in the TPJ,
we change that judgment.
And so that was our best
guess, that if any feature
of other people's
mental states is
represented in the right TPJ,
it would be that feature.
If MVPA was ever going
to be able to decode
a feature of other
people's mental states,
we should start there.
That was the idea.
OK, so here's how
these experiments go.
In every every trial you read
a long, complicated story
that sets up a murder.
So here's an example.
Your family's over for dinner.
You want to show off
your culinary skills
for one of the dishes.
Adding peanuts will
bring out the flavor.
So you grind up
peanuts and put them
in the dish and feed everyone.
Your cousin, one of
the dinner guests,
is severely allergic to peanuts.
You had absolutely no
idea about his allergy
when you added the peanuts.
And then at the end we ask
how much blame you should get.
Somebody asked me this earlier.
This is in the second
person and doesn't matter.
Somebody asked me if you could
do it in the second person,
and you can.
What's nice about
this experiment
is that we can do a
relatively minimal pair.
So in all of our
old experiments we
wrote one set of stories
about people's mental states
and a completely different set
of stories about other things.
And those stories are different
in many, many, many ways.
In this experiment, we
make one tiny change.
So we make, for example,
a change from you
had no idea to you knew.
We change on average
two to four words
in this whole long scenario.
So we can make these
tiny interventions.
It's a complicated stimulus,
but the change we make
is very small and
totally changed
the meaning of the
whole story by just
changing your mental state.
OK, what univariate
analyses would say is,
this is a really important fact.
Whether you knew or you didn't
know about your cousin's peanut
allergy is really important
to the moral judgment
of what happened.
We know that.
And it's represented
in the right TPJ,
because if we TMS
the right TPJ, you
make your moral judgments
of this distinction
specifically change.
But if you ask how much
does the right TPJ respond
to these stories, the
answer is the right
TPJ responds exactly equally
to these two conditions.
And the intuition is,
because in both cases
it matters what you think.
It matters that you knew, and
it matters that you didn't know.
And the right TPJ is tracking
the important information
about what you think.
And so it's activated for both
of these kinds of stories.
So that's a univariate analysis.
Now what's a
multivariate analysis?
So here's the key intuition
behind a multivariate analysis.
The idea is, think in a very
abstract similarity space.
If we take the two stories--
and so we take the story you
had no idea about your cousin's
allergy when you
added the peanuts.
That story is complicated.
It has many
important dimensions.
Now we take a new story.
This is a story about, for
example, a faulty parachute.
Within that story there's many,
many different dimensions.
It's about parachutes.
There's all kinds of
complicated things going.
But there's this one feature--
whether you knew or didn't know
that the parachute was faulty.
There's another story about
publicly shaming your classmate
by saying something
embarrassing about their essay.
So again, that's a
whole new scenario
with all kinds of
dimensions in it.
But there's this one feature.
Did you know or not know that
the person who wrote the essay
was in the room when you said
that publicly shaming thing?
A different story is
about demonstrating
your karate skills and
knocking out your classmate--
again, totally new
moral scenario.
But again, this
one feature-- did
you know or not know that
your classmate was there
when you did the kick?
Now here's the idea.
Even though each of
those new scenarios
is completely
different, if there
are different subpopulations
within your right TPJ
responding when you knew you
were going to cause harm--
compared to when you didn't know
you were going to cause harm--
then even though the pattern of
activity in your right TPJ will
be different on every trial--
because you're representing
a different person having
a different mental state
in a different context--
a little part of that
response will be the same.
Or it will be different
in the same way,
right, because the
same cell population
will be more active for all the
stories that have knowing harm.
And the other population
will be relatively
active in all the stories
that have the unknowing harm.
And so the logic is that if
we could look in the right TPJ
and measure the
pattern of activity--
and hope that reflects something
like the relative activation
of different cell populations
inside the right TPJ--
that the pattern
of activity would
be more similar for pairs or
subsets of stories that share
this one feature, and are
different in every other way,
compared to pairs that are
different in every other way
and don't share that feature.
OK, so this is
the central logic.
Take any two stories
within the set.
They're all unique.
So those two stories
that are different,
you're representing a new
mental state of a new person.
You have a new pattern
in your right TPJ.
But if they share
the feature that you
knew you were going
to cause harm,
that would be something a
little bit similar in your right
TPJ activation compared to if
they don't show that feature.
Does that logic make sense?
And so what you get is a
spatial pattern of activation.
So we're now not looking at how
much the right TPJ responded.
But within the space
of the right TPJ,
where was there a little bit
more or a little bit less
activity?
And these signals are
tiny compared to the thing
I showed you before.
So the amount of activity in
the right TPJ is a big signal.
The relative activity
between one voxel and another
is a tiny signal.
And it's superimposed
on a lot of noise.
But if there's
anything there at all,
then you'll still
be able to pick up
a little more
similarity for pairs
that are matched on
the feature of interest
compared to pairs
that are not matched
on the feature of interest.
That's the logic behind
a Haxby style analysis.
And so literally
what you do is, you
take the vector of responses
across all the voxels
inside a region, and
you correlate them
across subsets of your data.
And you ask whether the
correlation in space--
so what it looks like,
the spatial pattern
of activity over those voxels--
is more similar for
pairs that share
the feature you're interested
in compared to pairs
that don't share the feature
that you're interested in.
And what you get
at is two numbers--
the correlation
for pairs that do
share the feature
and the correlation
for pairs that don't
share the feature
for each individual subject.
And the question you ask in
a Haxby style correlation
is what's called the
within-condition correlation.
So the spatial correlation
of the response
to two independent sets
of stories that share
this one feature--
is the spatial pattern
more similar in that pair
compared to a pair that don't
share that feature, when
everything else is different?
And so what you get out
of an analysis like this--
for example, in our first
attempt to do this in these
stimuli--
there's these two correlations.
There's the
within-condition correlation
and the between-condition
correlation,
and you ask if
they're different.
OK, and what we got in
our first experiment
is that the within-condition
correlation is significantly
but a tiny bit stronger than the
between-condition correlation.
So there's a lot of
things to ask about this.
But the first question is--
is that real, or is
that a coincidence?
That is the first
thing you want to know
when you see data like this.
Afterwards, we can
ask what does it mean.
But let's start
with is that real.
And so the way that
you ask is it real is,
you just make sure that
it would replicate, that
in independent data you'd
get the same answer.
And so just before we set out
to actually replicate this
experiment, we remember
that we had actually
already run this experiment
two times before--
because we were studying
this process of representing
accidental and intentional
harms for a long time
before we thought of using MVPA.
So we had these
two old data sets
in the lab, two whole
independent experiments
in which people had read stories
about knowing and unknowing
harm.
And the other thing
is that we had
manipulated this distinction
in different ways
across the stimuli.
So in the example
I just told you,
the way that we did it is, we
said you knew about the allergy
or you didn't know
about the allergy.
But in the older experiments,
like this example
I gave you at the
beginning of the talk,
we had described two
different beliefs--
so either believing
that it's sugar
or believing that it's
poison, so no negation.
This is just important
because that's a different way
to create the same distinction.
And what you want to know is,
are you decoding the abstract
thing-- that she knew she
was causing harm or not--
or something less abstract,
like whether the story
has negation in it.
That's an alternative
possibility.
And so in experiments B and
C, we had done it this way.
It's also in the third
person, not the second person.
So if we find the
same result, then it
generalizes across all these
incidental features of the way
the experiment was run.
OK, that's experiment two,
and that's experiment three.
I also want to say that there's
some weird magical property
of being a scientist,
where if you don't
know the hypothesis when
you're running the experiment
and you have all the data and
then you go back and check,
there's something
more real about it
than if you knew the
hypothesis before you
ran the experiment-- even though
that makes no sense whatsoever.
There's just this
experience like,
if I had the
hypothesis in my head,
maybe it somehow got
from my head to the data.
But when the data
were already there
and then you went
back and analyzed them
and the effect was
hiding in the data
that you'd had on
your server, there's
something way more real
and magical about that.
So anyway, because it was
there in all of our old data,
I just believed it was true.
The other thing to notice about
this is, to get an MVPA signal,
we didn't change
anything about the fMRI.
We didn't change
the resolution--
the temporal resolution,
the spatial resolution.
You can know that for
sure, because these
are our old data that we had
before we started doing MVPA.
MVPA is not a technique
for collecting better data.
It's a technique for
getting more information out
of the same data.
It's an analysis technique.
It's a way of
thinking about data,
not a way of getting data.
OK, so what this says is
that however similar two
unrelated stories are about a
case in which somebody kills
somebody, they are
more similar if they
are both cases of knowing
murder or both cases
of unknowing murder than
if you cross that feature.
So just making that
future match makes
the pattern of neural
response in the right TPJ
more similar, suggesting
that which part of the right
TPJ is more or less active
contains information
about whether or
not the person who
committed the murder knew what
they were doing at the time.
This is specific
to the right TPJ.
So these are a bunch
of the other brain
regions involved in theory
of mind and social cognition.
And none of them
contain any information
about this dimension at all.
So this dimension is
represented in the right TPJ
and not represented
anywhere else.
There's another thing that
makes these data interesting.
People are reading
these stories,
and they're making
moral judgments.
And moral judgments of these
stories vary across people.
So some people tend to go more
with what the person thought,
whereas other people
tend to go more
with what the person caused.
It's not extreme
individual variability.
Everybody agrees that it's
worse to knowingly murder
than to unknowingly murder.
But there is variability
in how much worse.
Some people think that basically
what you thought you were doing
is all that matters
in these stories,
whereas other people think
both of those things matter.
So it matters to some degree
that you caused the murder
and to some degree
that you didn't know.
So there's individual
variability.
And one thing that
we can look at
is, how does the individual
variability in the behavior
relate to the
individual variability
in the representation.
So what this looks like is,
on the x-axis I measure--
for you, how much
worse are intentional
than accidental harms.
How much worse is
it when you knew
you were going to cause harm
than when you didn't know?
So that's always going
to be a positive number.
Everybody thinks it's worse.
But for some people,
it's a lot worse
than it is for other people.
And then relate that to,
while you were reading
that story, how different were
the patterns in your brain
when you were reading
about knowing harm
compared to unknowing harm.
Does that make sense?
They're pretty correlated.
So the more that you
represented knowing
harm as different
from unknowing harm
in your right TPJ,
the more that you
judged them as different when
we asked you for moral judgment.
And the pattern difference
in your right TPJ
accounts for 35% of the variance
in your moral judgment, which
is pretty amazing,
because that's
a pretty noisy measurement.
Actually it's both.
It's a pretty noisy
measurement of your brain
and a pretty noisy
measurement of your behavior.
So it's quite amazing that
those are that correlated.
So that's what's
cool about the data.
But we'll get to the method.
So Haxby style correlations--
these are called Haxby style
because they were the first
form of MVPA introduced,
and they were introduced
by Jim Haxby in 2001,
so actually a long time ago.
It took a long time
for other people
to recognize what a
cool technique this was.
But he had this idea
a very long time ago.
And the idea is, take
a region you care about
and ask this basic question.
For some future that I
wonder if it's represented,
is the correlation across
neural responses more similar
when the stimuli share
that feature than when
they don't share that feature?
So that gives you a
pretty robust measurement,
because you're using all
the voxels in the region
to get one number
out-- the correlation.
And you're doing it over
partitions of the data,
often halves of the
data, so many trials
are going into both
the train and test.
So in this case we're using
halves of the data, even halves
and odd halves.
And so each of the
things we're correlating
is a relatively less
noisy neural measure
because it has many
trials averaged into it.
So it's robust and simple.
In this case, it can be
sensitive to pretty minimal
stimulus variations.
As I showed you, this is a
two- to four-word variation
on an 80-word story.
So it's sensitive to small
distinctions in the stimuli.
Here we showed that
it generalizes.
So we used totally
independent stories
in the train and test set.
And so we're always generalizing
from one set of examples
to a totally different
set of examples.
It gave us a measure that was
stable within a participant
in the sense that the
measure in each individual
related to that
individual's behavior.
So it's characterizing
individuals
in a relatively stable way.
And we could show that it
differs across regions.
So we could show that this
was present in the right TPJ
but not present
in other regions.
And that's a bunch of stuff
you would want to know.
That's a whole bunch
of extra information
than we ever were
able to get before.
And I'll give you one
more example of the way
that Haxby correlations
can be used.
So in this case I showed you,
we hypothesized one dimension.
And we tried to
decode that dimension.
Obviously, you don't
only have to do one.
And so another way to do this
is to build stimulus sets that,
for example, have two
orthogonal dimensions
and ask about both of them.
SO here's an
experiment in which we
asked about decoding two
orthogonal differences
within the same set of stimuli.
So again, you're reading
stories about people
who are having experiences.
And some sets of
these stories vary.
So here's a bunch of stories.
Leslie has just been in a
big, important interview.
And he sees himself
in a mirror, and he
sees that his shirt has a big
coffee stain down the front.
And another one is--
Eric gets to a restaurant to
meet his fiance's parents,
and he sees them and
they're looking happy
So that's two completely
different stories.
And then the third story--
Abigail is painting
her dorm room,
and she hears somebody's
footsteps down the hallway.
And the footsteps sound like
her beloved boyfriend's.
So these stories
are all different.
Again, they're all But
the first two stories
I read you share
a feature, which
is that somebody in the
story is seeing something.
And they don't
share that feature
with the third story, in
which somebody in the story
is hearing something.
Does that makes sense?
Compared to, for example--
Quentin hears a phone
message, and the message
says she has bad
news to tell him.
That's another story
that shares this feature
that somebody in the story
is hearing something.
And so we can use this
set of stories to ask,
is the neural
response to stories
in which somebody
is seeing something
more similar within that set?
So one set of stories
about seeing something
is compared to another set of
stories about seeing something.
Are those stories more
similar to one another
than when you
cross that feature?
So you ask one set of stories
about seeing something
compared to one set of stories
about hearing something.
And so in the right
TPJ, what we found
is that stories about seeing are
more similar to other stories
about seeing.
And stories about
hearing are more
similar to other
stories about hearing
than when you
cross that feature.
But, as you may have
noticed, the stimulus set
had another distinction
in it, which
is whether the thing is good
or bad that's happening to you.
So finding out
after an interview
that you have coffee
down your shirt
or hearing a message that
says there's bad news,
those are both bad things.
Whereas seeing your fiance
looking happy or hearing
that your beloved boyfriend
is coming down the hallway,
those are both good things.
And so we could ask
in the same dataset,
what about stories that share
this feature of valence.
The pairs of stories that
are matched on valence,
do they have a more
similar neural signature
than the pairs of stories
that are crossed on valence?
And in the right
TPJ they're not.
We've actually found this
a whole bunch of times.
The right TPJ doesn't
care about valence.
Other regions do-- don't
worry-- we do represent valence.
But the right TPJ doesn't
represent valence.
So that's another way that
you can use this method--
hypothesize two or three
orthogonal dimensions
within the same stimulus set.
And then we can get, for
example, interactions
between these to say, OK,
the right TPJ does represent
some dimensions, doesn't
represent other dimensions--
in principle.
So you can test
potentially multiple
orthogonal distinctions.
There's a whole
bunch of limitations
of Haxby style correlations.
One of them is that all
the tests are binary.
The answer you get
for anything you test
is that there is or
is not information
about that distinction.
There's no continuous
measure here.
It's just that two things are
different from one another
or they are not different
from one another.
And so once people started
thinking about this method,
it became clear that
this is actually
just a special case of a much
more general way of thinking
about fMRI data.
This particular method,
using spatial correlations,
is very stable and robust.
But it's a special case of
a much more general set.